today's video is about a game you start
off with a deck of playing cards that
you actually instead of shuffling it
normally you flip a half of it over
every time you shuffle so that some of
the cards are going to wind up face-up
and some of them are gonna wind up
facedown
thank you I actually have to do it a
bunch of times because I truly want to
be randomized if it's face up or face
down so I don't want exactly 50/50 I
want them to be up or down as they may
then you pick a number and we're gonna
do it first with a small number so give
me a number between say 5 and 10 that's
scary 4 6 sex so you lay out 6 cards in
a row with the edges touching each other
the objective of the game is to wipe the
table of all the cards the way the game
is played is you can draw out a card
only when it's face up so right now I've
got 3 choices for which car that could
start by drawing out and the second rule
is that when you draw the card if it's
still touching either of its neighbors
if you flip over any of its remaining
neighbors so anything that's still
touching it gets flipped over how do you
choose your first card well it's kind of
like solitaire you wanna strategize so
that you win the game if you choose the
wrong card that's possible to mess the
whole thing up and winds up losing say I
choose this card right here so I draw it
out flip over both of its neighbors but
now this little island right here is
actually stuck no chance of either of
these cards getting flipped over I can't
pull them out I'm gonna lose the game if
you're going to play the game to win
you want to strategize a bit and then
let's say we start off with this Queen
we draw her out flip over the two
neighbors this is isolated but we can
draw this one out and then let's go
ahead and draw this end flip over this
two then draw this jacket flip over his
neighbors and we can draw out each of
these remaining two cards now I'm going
to deal out another six cards and see if
we can win the second game all right now
I can tell you right now this game is
not winnable even if I played with
optimum strategy nothing will work if I
try to remove this King
then it would flip over these two cards
and I can already see I've made a
mistake because this Islands over here
is never going to be able to be removed
so let me undo that if I try that say
this ten instead then I am going to be
able to remove this last card in the
islands now if I remove this club remove
the king but whichever of these two
cards I remove remove the two flip over
this Chaka if I remove the jack you'll
flip over this two and stuck forever
trust me you can't win this one so if
you're playing this game and you can
choose any number of cards to play with
what's the probability that you wind up
with a game that's impossible no matter
how well you play I've seen three
different beautiful proofs of us two of
them are very formal two of them are the
kinds of proof that if you're familiar
with inductive strategy proof or
breaking down a large game into smaller
parts you can do fairly like it formal
proofs that way but I'm going to show
you a proof that is based on jigsaw
puzzle pieces instead of the one that it
was the first proof I ever wrote mmm I
have some I guess nostalgia for it
because of that so spoiler if you play
this game a million times you'll find
that approximately half of those times
that you'll be able to win it playing
perfectly and half the times you'll have
laid out a scenario that's impossible to
ever win can you tell by looking at it I
can I can tell just by scanning across
the cards once what are you looking for
what are you looking at to give it away
we're not telling me you're looking
specifically at the number of faceoff
cards and you're looking to see if
there's an even number of them or an odd
number of them total and if they're an
even number of them then you're very sad
or you say Deal again if they're an odd
number you give the green light and you
try to play it let's try a slightly
larger game this time can you pick a
number between ten and twenty thirteen
thirteen all right thirteen cards
so there's five because they're an odd
number of face-up cards if you play this
perfectly you'll be able to win prove it
excellent so I'm actually gonna do more
than just prove that this game is what I
could do that
by playing it and showing you that
Quentin instead that I'm going to show
you a way to prove that for any odd
number of face-up cards you can win that
game I could start with this card right
here and that would flip both of its
neighbors then this card then that would
flip this one over so that could be my
third okay say I go down here for the
fifth and here's something that I really
love is going to happen to draw this
card you wind up with what I think of as
a fuse going down to the left it just
kind of burns down that straight and
that could also burn off to the right so
say this is five and go ahead and call
this six seven eight then this card
right here next I'll burn down this
Trika ten eleven twelve thirteen I can
remove this in this order and just show
and you can like move my hands super
fast
[Music]
well success all right cool
let's reload it now let's look at the
proof for why any are the number of
face-up cards can be one so if you look
at this particular sequence you can see
that follows two rules that match the
rules of the game mainly that if I've
got a face-up card then I can draw that
before either of its neighbors or I can
draw that after both of its neighbors
but if I've drawn out one of its
neighbors and not the other
it'll be flipped over and it's taka so 5
is less than both 10 and 6 because of
this if a card is face down then it's
stuck initially but if I draw one of its
two neighbors either one in this case
this card gets drawn out first it'll
flip over and I'll be able to draw it
out as long as I don't also draw out the
card to the other side of it so it has
to be before one of its neighbors and
after the other so face up cards are
either going to have to be less than
both of the neighbors or greater than
both of the neighbors so this one this
one is less than both this 4 is greater
than both now this 3 is face down 3 it
has to be greater than one neighbor and
less than the other so that's been
flipped over exactly once and we can
draw that 3 is greater than 2 at the end
here nothing to the right of that so
this card because it's face up but
absolutely has to be drawn up before its
neighbor if this car were drawn out
first this would be stuck forever long
dis son 10 is less than 11 which is less
than 12 which is less than 13 right here
in the centre 6 a is less than 7 just
less than 8 so I played a bunch of games
when I was trying to figure out how the
pair of us then I looked at this sort of
greater-than less-than sequence and it
started to look a lot like a jigsaw
puzzle to me and I realized that all the
face-up cards it looked like one of two
kinds of pieces they either looked like
these sort of diamond shades pieces or
they looked like these kind of concave
pieces
this one here in the center connecting
the nine and the four piece and then for
all of the facedown cards every single
piece looks exactly the same double to
the left or double to the right so so I
just made one kind for that and started
putting them in the either moving to the
right or to the left and then the two
ends are something special the two ends
are completely forced to based on if
it's face up or face down if it's face
down then it absolutely has to be drawn
after its neighbor because it's stuck to
begin with so greater then makes the
piece look like this on the other hand
if it's face up then it absolutely has
to be drawn before its neighbor if I
drew out this card first this one we get
stuck so I better had gone that out
before the card next to it so I created
these two pieces for the possibilities
of the ends
all right so again we've drawn that one
that has five face up cards so this is
going to be solvable but have no clue
what were there will work and I'll show
you how to use the pieces to both see
that it's solvable and see what wearing
will work so starting from the left
because this card is face up it has to
be drawn out earlier so with an order
that's a less than its neighbor in this
card being face up means that I have a
choice either after both of its
neighbors or before so this is after or
there is a number on this card that's
greater than both of its neighbors and
this one would be before both of its
neighbors and well I'm choosing between
these but only one of them agree is with
the card to the left of it so the choice
is actually completely forced I have to
put down this one so then moving on this
one's face down that means it has to be
earlier than one neighbor and less than
the other but we already know that it's
going to be earlier than this one which
means it has to be earlier and then less
than its right neighbor I'm just going
to keep going down and for every
facedown card this is the shape that has
to be it's either going to be to the
left or to the right but it's always
going to be forced by what came before
it for face-up cards I have to put down
that the one that fits next to it's a
blue piece just laid so let's fill it up
now it's the moment of truth we've got
one card at the end and two possible
pieces for this facedown card though it
has to be drawn out after its neighbor
no choice there so we'd better hope that
it's number that the number of its order
we'd better hope that the order is
larger than the card next to it in this
case it can be this sign right here
saying that this number can be larger
than this number therefore this is the
piece that fits that's good the green
pieces are the ones that go with a
facedown card on the edge so it except
when luckily luckily it accepts that
it's receiving it exactly and if it had
happened
to be a faceoff card here on the edge
meaning that there are six total face-up
cards a this wouldn't have worked this
would have had to be drawn out before
its neighbor it would have been stuck
there forever meaning that it would need
this piece under it but this piece
doesn't fit so I'm very happy that we've
got facedown card on the edge we
actually can actually use this to see
how to win the game in particular we can
see that the cards that need to be drawn
out early are the cards that have the
smallest values theirs are going to be
the yellow cards you can draw those out
in either order you can do this whole
side of the game before this side of the
game but this card has to be drawn out
before both of its neighbors in fact
that any sequence of removing that the
cards that follows these rules for which
parts of the order are earlier or later
is going to be a winning way to play
this game how do you know that you can't
deal out an even number of face ups and
still make a jigsaw that works I'm very
glad you asked that question there's the
question of the day to help answer the
question let me introduce you to my
hedgehog oh what's his name you want me
to name him Calvin the Hedgehog Calvin
the Hedgehog is a bit fussy in
particular he likes to go on walks oh
but whenever he reaches an arrow he has
to go over it in the way that's aligned
with his nose so if he's reaching an
arrow that points to the left he
actually is going to turn around and
start going backwards until he reaches
an arrow that faces to the right again
he's gonna swish it and keep going he
can get to the end both him first he
just has to get yes he can get to the
end but first bottom bottom he can get
to the end bottom first but he has to
reach all the way from the left side
that's the right side and he is
incredibly fussy so if he ever has to
break the rules he's not willing to
proceed so you asked me why an even
number of face-up cards wouldn't work
and the answer is if you imagine Calvin
starting at the begin
going over the cards every time there's
a face-up card including at the very
beginning it causes Calvin to turn
[Music]
now at the end here we can actually
figure out which direction he's facing
just by looking at how many face-up
cards there were because those are the
only points when he turned and if he's
turned around a even number of times so
if he starts off going ahead and then
turns one two
he's back to forward three four back to
forward if he turns an even number of
times if they're an even number face-up
cards and he's going to be going the
same direction as he started if he
starts on the picture card then he has
to start off pointing to the left so
walking but first and then every time he
reaches a face-up card he'll turn around
this means that if there are an even
number of face-up cards after this first
one which means an odd number total
he'll wind up facing backwards at the
very end and if he's facing backwards at
the very end then the last car that
absolutely has to be one that fits in
with this arrow an arrow pointing left I
mean that absolutely has to be a
facedown card so in total you'll have an
odd number of face-up cards if at the
beginning your first card is face down
well that changes the entire puzzle
sequence all the way across and you'll
have a Hedgehog that gets to start going
forward and then if it passes over an
odd number face-up cards it will have
turned around backwards if it passes
over an even number of face-up cards it
will have turned around so that it's a
you know backwards forwards backwards
turns around until it's facing
ultimately forwards again so replacing
this card here with a reverse every
single piece in the row every red block
would become yellow and every blue block
would have to change directions and by
the time you get to the end you'd need
the opposite kind of card in order to
complete it so ultimately if this one
winds up face-up and has to be down this
one down ends up and that's based on the
number in the middle if the number in
the middle is odd then the ends have to
match if the number in the middle is
even then the ends have to be different
do you ever play this game anymore or
was playing this game boring because you
because you always know that was over
now I like to play this game with people
who have never played
before because if you give them a long
sequence of cards even though it might
be possible to win it you might know how
if they're an odd number of face-up
cards in the middle if they pick the
wrong ones and the wrong order then they
can still lose the game mm-hmm so
they're still you know some strategy
involved and that moment where you
realize oh they just flipped over that
card and I know they're doomed they
don't see it yet but I know they're
doomed and I guess I like that moment
all right I'm going to ask you to pick a
number between 10 and 20 and you're
going to say 13 all right now let's try
playing a longer game pick a number
between 10 and 20 this time
[Laughter]